(light instrumental music)
- Camouflage is important in the oceans.
It's a cutthroat world
outside these submarine walls.
Today, we're talking about seahorses,
and their ability to camouflage.
(suspenseful instrumental music)
My grandfather Jacques
Cousteau always stood out
in a crowd because of his style,
but these seahorses do just the opposite.
Seahorses are masters of camouflage,
and the pygmy seahorse is one of
the most well-camouflaged
species in the ocean,
and the smallest variety
of seahorses that exist.
They're the size of a paperclip.
In fact, the pygmy
seahorse wasn't discovered
until someone was examining
a piece of coral it was on.
(light string music)
Seahorses, much like
chameleons, can change color.
They change color to confuse predators,
as well as to convey
emotions to one another,
especially during courtship.
The speed at which they change color,
well that depends on what's happening.
As a response to fear, it's rapid,
whereas if it's due to hormonal
changes, it's much slower.
- It's gone.
- What, what do you mean
it's gone? (sighing)
No, no, no, no, it's right there.
Stealthy seahorse.